what's up jesse how are we doing um how
do adult children create boundaries with
parents
when they're still siblings at home
give me an example walk me through it
yeah um well
i've listened to like some of your shows
that
well my mom is has a lot of
narcissistic personality traits and i
have a lot of siblings
five of them are out of the house and
several
more are still living in the house how
many siblings do you have
i have 12 siblings is that a girl way to
go dude
that's a whole other show right yeah
so so five are out and
i guess i'm bad at math but that the
rest of them are at home
um like six more are at home wow okay
so um anyway but with my mom
uh i think me and several of my
other siblings are really struggling
with creating boundaries
um with mainly my mom but also
my parents um and like i've listened to
a lot of your shows where you've given
advice
to you know create boundaries such as
you know we'll have thanksgiving and
christmas without you until you can
figure out
your marriage and in some ways that
applies
and like limiting contact also applies
uh until i just think about like i can't
leave my siblings
like i can't leave the rest of the ones
at home and
and and i and i feel like lost there
because
you know i feel like whenever i'm
leaving
or creating boundaries it really goes to
my siblings also are they are your
siblings safe
um yeah okay are they
um being emotionally neglected are they
being beat up
what what are the things what are the
things your mom's doing that says
that you are having to draw a line you
cannot be around me you can't be around
my family
um
i i think i've so i've been out of the
house for eight years
um and i've had to go to like tons of
therapy
for myself just to go through a lot of
that stuff
um you're giving me lots and lots of
words
what is it about your mom yeah um
she like you don't know what it's like
unless you're living there like there's
a really good person that's what i'm
trying to ask you
you're so good it's hard because it's
like gosh i haven't worked there for so
long i think that i've forgotten
how bad it is she's really manipulative
but you you have made the decision
i i don't want my my mom in my life yeah
and
i i trust you that's the right decision
all i'm asking you is why have you made
that decision eight years later that i'm
done
she's hurt like me
and like just the words that she used
growing up
um were really hurtful like for a long
time i just
like i wanted to feel loved and a lot of
my siblings
were also struggling with that same
thing and when i lived at home
i would beg them like i was so depressed
as a teenager
and like um
i just needed help like really badly and
i would go to the hospital with chest
pain
from how much anxiety i had and like we
had
social workers coming in checking on us
um
and you know nothing and we were so
scared like all of us kids we were so
scared about being taken away and
everything we were like the perfect
family but my mom she just she's
emotionally hurtful
um like when i lived there
um she would go away to a room for like
days
on end and like my dad is still at home
or he
yeah so my my parents are together and
um and he
didn't like while i was living there he
didn't really have a lot to do
like he kind of checked out he would get
home and take over
house responsibilities and stuff and my
mom would check out and
my dad was just not not there
and so let me tell you let me tell you
this
it is really hard to grow up in the
house of parents
that have mental health issues
because they look normal they
present normal and then they disappear
right
yeah and you feel whispers or ghosts of
the person you think they should be or
that you desperately need them to be and
they're
not and in some ways it feels like it
would be easier if they just weren't
there because there's not that
disconnect between i know they're right
in that room and what is it about me
that they won't even come out of that
room to see their own kid
right it's almost easier if they're just
not there
because they can't come see you because
they're in another state right
yes and um sorry
go ahead um yeah and and it just was
like the only time that they
that my my mom would ever say anything
good about me
was like uh when i would do something
really good
and like she could post it on social
media being like you know look at my
daughter
you know she graduated at the top of her
class and then like that was the only
good thing that was ever said otherwise
like the word she used is i was the
poison of the family
because i was the oldest one living at
home at the time
and i would like beg my parents like can
we please you know we need help
like i don't like my siblings are coming
to me asking for help and i don't know
what to do and
you know we need counseling or family
counseling and
and i was just the poison of the family
at that time
um listen listen listen they shouldn't
have told you that
i'm sorry
no parent should ever tell their kid
that they're poison
okay that should never have happened and
i'm sorry that that did
and you're going to have a two-fold
thing going on here number one
you've got to take care of yourself your
boundaries are yours
nobody else's they're not your brothers
and sisters they're not
um your mom and dad's not your grandpa
they're yours
okay and so you have to develop those
strong boundaries
apologize to no one they are what they
are so that you can function and be
whole and well
okay the second thing is if your
brothers
and sisters the seven kids still living
in that home
are experiencing what you're
experiencing now then you have an
obligation to call somebody
those are two separate things okay
and
they're just children and unfortunately
it's landed in your lap
and you've got to make that phone call i
think
i think you know that i don't know
i don't i don't know okay um if you're
listening
so surreal it is and you're in the
middle of it
and if it blows up everything
that won't be your fault you will have
helped solve an issue that's been
ongoing for years and years and years
and years
okay okay and
if your brothers and sisters are being
neglected for days on end
if they are calling you crying saying
help help help
then yeah you've got to help that's a
that's what a big sister does that's
what a community member does you got to
make that phone call
and if your dad can hear it then you
start with him and say i'm giving this
one month now i'm going to call social
worker and go get the kids
because i'm not doing this i do i do
have something about that
um my my dad um
my dad sorry my
one of my other brothers who's also out
of the house
took my dad out to breakfast because
my mom was concerned about his mental
health and so was my brother
um and
and then my dad kind of revealed like
this huge
pretty much his disgust with my mom and
their marriage and everything and
absolutely um and
he's also dealing with a lot of mental
health
issues and and that's part of why this
became a thing now like for me
specifically is
because i am concerned about my siblings
um
like jesse jesse like
you can't fix your mom and dad you can't
you can never achieve your way to being
loved by them
there's not a right way to make this
call there's not a
right way to tell them i don't want you
all in my life for the next season
while i heal there's not a there's not a
way to do that that they can hear it and
be like that's cool we get it
they can't they're not well
and your whole life has been about
making sure
they leave you alone that they are okay
so you can go about doing your thing
even to the point that you gave up your
thoughts and your dreams
and the things you want to do so you
could get the right grades so your mom
could post the right thing about her
poison daughter
right great and eight years out of that
house you're
still living in it still and you have
these imaginary conversations
over and over about if i could just sit
down and say this
and not say that and right am i crazy no
that's right
and it's exhausting
and you are poisoning yourself every day
hoping that they die
and that's just not going to work that
way
i think i wonder to myself like
is it even the right thing to call
someone because
like i just have it in my head like and
people
i've talked to people since then they're
like well you know
most of you guys have turned out fine so
far you know it's
you hey jesse you're not fine
and you know that you are really really
good at performing
you're good at it academy award level
you're not fine
right right
just thinking about how your mom talked
to you
opens a wound up right it's right there
at the surface you've done a lot of
therapy so you can get through a day and
have normal relationships and friends
you're not okay
what would that look like for my
siblings
every single situation is different
that's why this is
messy and i want you to be under no
illusions that this is a simple thing
do you get with the other five brothers
and sisters and say hey we're all gonna
have to figure this out
we're gonna take have a group call here
because i'm not letting this happen
or do you meet with your mom and dad
together and say if you all don't start
seeing somebody and getting medicated
and start getting well
i'm gonna do what i can to get these
kids out of this house and it may look
like those kids going two of them going
to one brother and one of them going to
one sister
here's the thing there is not a way that
this isn't messy going forward
it's messy if you don't say anything
then that cycle continues it's messy if
you blow the whole thing up and call
the child protective services of your
state or area and they come in swarming
it's messy if you call a social worker
who says we're gonna
teach your mom and dad and get them help
they need it's messy
just regardless and i hate this for you
you didn't ask for this you don't
deserve this but it just is
and you should not be having to do this
by yourself you should have brothers and
sisters who know exactly what your
other one what the siblings are going
through and they do is that right
oh yeah we actually we've had a little
meeting
this year already to discuss my dad's
mental health
okay so and i just think that
it just feels i don't want to say
extreme because i i don't know if it's
extreme or not but to call social
services on my
own parents and to um you know and my
siblings living there like
they'll do normal activities too but you
you just don't hear
like it's just not spoken of unless you
know
um like my my youngest or one of my
younger brothers
living at home saw my dad sitting on the
bed with a gun
just because my dad was suicidal at the
time
and like that's just stuff i don't want
my siblings to go through
jesse jesse listen
do you hear with the words coming out of
your mouth
you got to make that call and you
probably got to get all your brothers
and sisters together and you all have to
decide together this is going to be the
weekend we do this
and if your dad hauls off and takes his
own life that is not on you
it's not if your mother says see i told
you so after all these years that's not
on you
if they uncover all sorts of things with
interviewing your brothers and sisters
it's just a mess and it may be that your
dad is begging begging begging
begging for somebody to reach out and
say hey you're not okay
let's get you the help you need let's
get you somewhere it may be that your
mom
is begging begging begging here's the
thing you can't solve your mom and dad's
problems they have to decide
they want to get well but if you've got
underage kids
in that house walking in on your dad
holding a gun
you can't you got to step in you got to
make that call
you have to okay jesse
i hate this for you i hate this for your
brothers and sisters i hate this for
anybody who is trying to stop
generational or
legacy abuse and emotional trauma
and trying to love their parents through
mental
illness it's so hard it's devastating
tears upon tears loss of sleep
but that doesn't mean it's not the right
thing
what i want you to do is to go see i
want you before you make any phone calls
i want you
jesse to go call somebody
whether that's an online therapist
whether it's an in-person therapist i
want you to go meet with somebody and
say
i'm gonna weigh in here the time has
come for me to weigh in and it's gonna
be hard and i want you to get a game
plan with a professional therapist
then call in your brothers and sisters
and say here's the game plan here's what
we're going to do
and then somebody's going to volunteer
and say we're going in
we're going to sit down with mom and dad
and say here's what's about to happen
and we're going to get the kids out of
that house and we're going to split them
up among the brothers and sisters until
things are well
or we're going to call services or y'all
are going to commit to x y or z dad
you're going to get committed mom you
have to step up
this is not y'all's house to run but
those kids need somebody to step in and
advocate for them they need an ally
soon today because you know why you
needed that too
and i hate the fact that nobody showed
up for you jesse i hate it i hate it i
hate it
and now's your chance you and your
brothers and sisters to turn and face
this forest fire that's
raging through your family and say no
more we're done
we don't even know how this is gonna
look and it's gonna be a disaster
but we're turning we're going to face
this thing down no more
let me know how that goes let me know
that session goes live and how that
conversation goes
do not think this is going to be easy
this is the hardest thing you've had to
do
that doesn't mean it's not right often
the hardest things we have to do are
the righteous things we have to do